il faut absolument comme l'a dit le
président du sénat que nous ayons enfin
droit à un débat clair ça fait des
semaines ça fait des mois même que l'on
voit les allers-retours y compris
parfois les contradictions au sein du
gouvernement sur un sujet qui est
pourtant majeur quand on parle des
retraites on ne parle pas d'un sujet
technique on parle de ski d'abord
correspond à l'effort d'une vie de
travail et donc de la dignité du travail
et puis on parle aussi bien sûr de
l'avenir de nos aînés dans un moment où
la question de la dépendance inquiète
beaucoup de familles il est tout à fait
nécessaire d'avoir enfin de la clarté